throughout this course you're gonna need
to test your site on different devices
so pull out your credit card and get
ready to order all of these devices that
you see behind you Peter I don't think
we can ask everybody to do that fair
enough
instead you could just use a simulator
or emulators simulators and emulators
are great tools well they're not always
a hundred percent accurate because
they're on different hardware and
sometimes have a different code path
they'll often get the job done and for
this course we'll be just fine in this
course cam and I are going to use an
emulator built into Chrome
but be sure to check out some of the
other ones including the iOS simulator
and some of the cloud-based services in
the instructor notes nice I like that a
lot more emulation is definitely the
much cheaper solution it is here let me
show you how it works